get on your knees you have three seconds
to comply
three you wanted new drug you could have
just asked me
the device that controls every military
satellite in the world was fallen into
the hands of four very dangerous gas we
need someone who can move like them
right like them it's time to be Patriots
there are no more Patriots just rebel
and tyrants so which are you
I'm xxx I'll introduce you to your
ground team all right it comes Red Bulls
poster self clowns watch my back who
would you trust that's a team like a
work
it's refreshing if you know what you're
doing down there yeah that's what she
says Wow these guys have you all saw the
real kind of trouble you have no idea
what you're up against
whatever it is they're looking for we're
gonna come off short this mean you're
not making me breakfast in the water
we're willing to die to keep the world
safe how about you I live for this I
guess we're on the same team now you
ready to have some fun I go look
maybe simple fast we kick some ass get
the girl and tried to look dope why are
you doing
dan it feels good to be back
you